pull a patient at umc is dead and
another injured after police say a man
pulled out a knife and stabbed them it
happened in the psychiatric section of
the hospital early this morning joe
moller is live this afternoon outside of
umc with what we know so far joe
according to police that man who stabbed
two other people was also a patient here
they say he left his room went to
another room stabbed a man and that man
ended up dying and then stabbed another
person in the hallway now there's a lot
of questions about how this all unfolded
in the hospital
early thursday morning a homicide
investigation was underway at umc police
say a patient stabbed two other people
inside the psychiatric area that suspect
a male in his 40's was found in his room
and taken into custody for the purposes
of safety the hospital
tries to keep psychiatric patients in a
certain area so they can staff those
units dr sid karuna is from nevada
mental health he says patients in the
psychiatric area of the hospital are
seeking out where to go for care and are
assessed a lot of patients go to the umc
emergency room to get a medical
clearance to make sure there is nothing
else medically going on right now it is
not known how the man got the knife into
the hospital or where it came from i've
been through the psychiatric ward as a
police officer david colemeyer is a
retired police officer from henderson
and new york city there normally is
security that's there and sometimes
correctional officers as well depending
upon the situation he has questions
about how this all happened you know how
did the person get the night didn't come
in in general did they do a good enough
search in general before that he
believes medical and mental health
facilities will be paying close
attention to the investigation and i'm
sure from this incident everybody in the
valley will probably change their
protocol depending upon how they found
out how the knife basically you know
wound up to this person that was
mentally unstable inside that ward a
statement released by umc ceo mason van
gaaling expressed support and the need
for mental health services in the county
ben howing also said many mentally ill
patients are sent to umc when they
belong at facilities better suited to be
treating their needs
now back out here live despite this
investigation that was going on
throughout the day umc did remain open
and they are open right now reporting
live joe mohler live local now